I used to watch this perfect couple  they were the embodiment of true love  I want to start my life over again  I saw her I saw her from the train she  was she was with this man just for a  second somewhere is this her to a woman  so can you tell me where you were Friday  night I was in the city and then I went  to visit my husband you mean your  ex-husband it's my understanding that  the woman who has gone missing who is  his nanny hey Tom Hagen Rachel why are  you here because I'm helping find Megan  I don't think you're helping anybody  I saw your wife with someone megan has a  therapist steadily saw  what happened that night McDonald tell  me the truth I read once that when a  train hits they can rip the clothes  right off of you you were seen in the  area that night  did you murder Megan hip well no  just tell me what happened that night  why are you here because I'm afraid of  myself  you